I've been all through time.
We've got to fix this.
Okay.
But be lost forever.
Great.
This entire place is going to be destroyed
if one shot at this.
Whatever we do. We're playing God.
What could we have done differently?
Just watch.
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie.
This will be my Loki
Season 2 Episode 2 Trailer Video
There's a bunch of Easter Eggs
and footage, so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
We're also doing a giveaway for the Loki
Blu rays.
All you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber
and just post all your predictions
based on the footage.
careful for spoilers.
If you haven't seen episode one yet.
Some of this footage though,
also seems like it's from other future
episodes, like episode three,
maybe a little bit beyond that too.
Marvel does that
with a lot of their trailers.
Will they mix in footage from like way
later episodes to but we see Loki time
slipping to Sylvie's
McDonald's in Broxton, Oklahoma, meaning
that they haven't completely
fixed the problem of him
time slipping like they saved him
at the very end of episode one.
So it seemed like they were done.
but there's all this footage of him
jumping through different points
in the timeline,
like you see him later in the TVA
with everything turning into spaghetti,
seeming like the TVA
still winds up almost being destroyed
no matter what they did in episode one.
I think this gets back to the whole
concept of the title of episode
one or A borrows in time repeating itself.
So even though they tried to fix things
in episode one, we're
going to keep repeating certain events,
like Loki will keep time slipping,
seeing things from a later in the season.
Like we'll actually see the scenes
from different perspectives
in future episodes.
But. At some point he time slips
to the McDonald's and Broxton, Oklahoma.
And that's probably how he finds out
that Sylvie is hiding out.
They're like, Wait a minute,
it's Sylvie. What's she doing here?
one of the notable things here, too,
is that Brock's in Oklahoma.
Where Sylvie went to is the location
of New Asgard in the comics.
The fact that she traveled to Braxton,
of all places, in time in space,
she could have gone to
Because she had he who remains tempered.
She literally could have gone anywhere
in the universe in time and space
or any other universe that she wanted to.
this might be just like a low level
reference to Thor
Loki always wanting to seek out home
in times of need and just a wink at this
being home in the comics new Asgard in
the MCU is built on the site
where Odin died.
There was a monument to him
during Thor Love and thunder
it was meant to be the same Nordic town
from the first Thor movie, Tom's Burg,
the same place where he later
hid the tesseract, implying that over
the centuries Odin just grew to love that
town and kept going back there.
like that was one of his vacation homes
the reason why Thor built new Asgard
in Broxton in the comics was because
it was near where he was resurrected.
Like, oh, hey,
why don't we just build home here?
there's a bunch more scenes of Sylvie
at that McDonald's working.
I explained a little bit in my episode
one video
why she decides to stay at the McDonald's.
The whole idea is that she just thinks
it's this really happy place,
in a sort of a vibe
that she's never experienced growing up
because she's always been on the run.
all these people coming to this place
to celebrate birthdays, relationships,
just hanging out with their friends.
And she's never been around
this kind of positive energy.
So she just wants to stay around it
for as long as possible.
the whole joke with her
not wanting to eat anything with a face
would normally mean she's a vegetarian.
but she also mentions
she doesn't want to eat any rats
or like other small creatures,
which would be meat as well.
So that's kind of redundant.
So that these joke might be more
of a literal kind of joke, like
please don't literally feed me
anything with an actual face on it.
They also released a bunch of promos
of them finding Sylvie
at this McDonald's
with the Raphael Casal character.
But it's not clear
if he's the zany version of the character
from the other trailers
or he's still the same Hunter
X5 character from episode one.
so this could be another variant of Hunter
X five in Sylvie's Universe
that she travel to,
or it could be that same character
who's working for General Docks.
there's still a ton of questions
about those two characters.
they also might have
just had him here at this McDonald's
for the purposes of this
funny McDonald's promo
because they did a bunch of
McDonald's integrations before the series
just to promote Loki in general.
but if some of these scenes are taken
from episode two,
that would also imply that the zany stuff
also happens in episode two.
Like they go back to that movie
premiere to capture this zany actor
and bring him back to the TVA
and interrogate him
there are a bunch of scenes of Loki
doing that inside the TVA the same way.
MOBIUS The other agents would interrogate
a normal variant.
look.
How proud Mobius must be of Loki here.
How much he's grown since season one.
Like the tables have turned.
This was happening to Loki
at the very beginning of the Loki series.
Now, Loki himself is doing it
this might be part of the mystery of
what's going on
with general dogs in Hunter X5.
Like something really
suss is going on with those two
and that's what all the jetski talk was
in episode one.
Like, why would they be giving him
so many scenes in episode one?
Why would he be making fun of Mobius
Jetskis so much unless something weird
was going on with the character?
The other thing
too, about those final scenes
from episode one,
when Loki time slips to the future
and everyone is in the middle
of evacuating the TVA,
the timeline seems like
it's about to be destroyed in the monitor,
like it's lights out for the TVA
for time and space.
And then everything in the trailer here
is turning into spaghetti,
paying off or Boris's joke
about black holes and spaghetti ification,
what might actually be going on
when this is happening is Loki actually,
time slipped forward
to the very end of the season, like this
scene is from the end of the season.
But we'll see them
from different perspectives
to explain more about
what's actually happening in this scene.
Notice when Sylvie found him
in the elevator here.
It's from after
she returns with Loki to the TVA.
Like the jacket
she's wearing is from later episodes.
this is future Sylvie,
not the Sylvie we saw in the Post-Credits
scene like that.
Sylvie Right after the end of the season
one finale.
Eventually Loki finds her,
brings her back, she gets this jacket,
and then at some later episode,
she finds him in the elevator.
that moment, him getting the mystery phone
call, the other third person behind them
that we can't see pruning him could have
all been things in the final episode
it is just a reference back to time
repeating itself.
The whole concept of borrows,
which is why they use that in episode one.
maybe throughout the season
time will keep repeating itself
like Loki continues to jump forward
and backwards through the timeline.
So we get teasers for things
in future episodes,
but in the future episodes,
we'll just see those moments
from different perspectives
that will fully explain things.
the other major new scenes here
seemed like Viktor Timely
Kang during that world's fair
in 1890 Chicago
they even had some extra footage of him
recently with like him clapping
and being really excited, working
with Loki and the other characters,
Marvel's making it seem like Viktor
Timely.
Kang comes back to the TVA at some point.
Is there helping Loki or a the others
with that same problem
of fixing the timeline
and stopping his time slipping?
I think the whole idea
there is because he's a Kang.
So they go looking for a Kang
that can help them because Loki assumes
he who remains is still dead.
And normally they would go to him like,
you're the person that created
all this stuff. Help us fix it.
And they just need someone
who designed the TVA technology.
So most of the Kang variants would have
some sort of idea of how to do that
because a lot of their technology
was shared.
Like they had that whole teaser
during season
one where we had the Council of Kings.
We shared technology across universes
until eventually some people just wanted
to conquer the multiverse.
So the idea is that Victor
Timely Kang is like a helpful Kang
who's willing to work with them.
But most of the other Kang's are evil
this is where we get to other future
episodes.
I'm not sure all this Victor
timely stuff is just from episode two.
This could be from like episode three,
just because it seems like there's
so much stuff going on in the trailer.
what they might do in episode
two is just focus on getting Sylvie back
with all the McDonald's stuff,
maybe a little bit of that zany stuff
and then tease what's going on with her
Von Arryn slayer so that in episode three
we see her during that world
fair in the 1890s, knows that she's there
where they go to find Victor timely.
Now they're not there to find ransom.
She just happens to be
there as well. For some reason.
But speaking of Ren Slayer,
there's still so many questions
about what's going on with her.
The message on the tape in the TVA
at the beginning of the Thibs timeline
makes it sound like she helped.
Hee, who remains, can create the TVA
in the first place,
like the mother of the TVA.
they sort of hint
at their romantic relationship
in that tape,
the way that he talks about her
calling her a marvel,
quote unquote, dropping
a big Marvel comic book reference.
In the comics, they weren't husband
and wife
or anything like that,
but he was in love with her.
They did have some kind of relationship
for a period of time.
So it sounds like at some point
he remains.
Kang fell in love with her
during the first Kang Multiverse war.
He took her with him to the future
to fight and win the war.
And then they started their relationship.
And after they won the war,
they created the TVA together.
this actually confirms
a lot of the coronavirus
theories that people had in season one.
So a lot of people felt like
the TVA was meant to be.
The MCU version of Chronos
is from the comics, which was the city
that Immortals creates in the distant
future to rule all of time.
That's basically what he remains,
King says in this message to Raven.
TRANSLATOR In the past, like,
I would be happy to rule all this with you
in the comics, eventually Immortals leaves
everything to her and then he departs.
And that's
kind of what he who remains king did
it sounds like they just lived
for hundreds and hundreds of years
ruling the TVA together
until he eventually grew bored of it.
At some point,
like many, many hundreds of years later.
then he creates the timekeepers and he
retreats to his citadel at the end of time
and just lives out for the rest of time
until Sylvie in Loki show up.
but this explains why in present day
Rensselaer didn't remember
creating the TVA with he remains king
he just wiped her memory at some point.
But he still loved her, apparently
because in the finale
he sent a message to her
through Miss minutes to escape.
when she's on the run,
she finds Victor timely.
KANG And that's how she gets caught up
with the Loki characters again.
there's a scene from the Parana
jetski dealership.
I think that's meant to pay off the time
slipping.
And Mobius is talk about the jet ski.
Maybe eventually
we'll see him on a jet ski at some point.
the key lime pie
scene of them in the automat
also seems like it's from episode two.
There's another scene of Silvie
talking to them in the Automat.
That might be after
she comes back in episode two,
this scene of Loki and Sylvie,
combining their powers
to take out the other two
guards in the building,
might be from a later episode too.
I'm assuming these two guards
that they're fighting
are general docks, guards
that we saw going with her in episode one.
They're trying to capture Sylvie.
There are a lot of theories about her
being the mother of Hunter X5 and that's
why she was treating him so weirdly,
like he was acting almost like a puppy
standing beside her and she treated him
like a mother would treat his son.
the whole thing is that in the TVA,
you're not supposed to have relationships
like that.
Normally
they would prove someone like that
If you had a child, they would prove him.
just more evidence that she's not exactly
who she says she is.
it also seems like at some point
in episode two, they travel back to
he remains at the end of time
in the episode just to see what happened.
General Dogs teased that too.
Like we need to go to the end of time
to find Sylvie
and find out what really happened.
so based on the footage,
just post all your theories
about what goes down in episode two.
Some of this, like I said,
might be from episode three, though.
My. Bull Episode
two Video will post next week
after they release
that There's supposed to be a couple other
big trailers for upcoming Marvel movies
soon, and they just confirmed that they've
already cast the new Fantastic Four movie,
but they're waiting till after
the actors strike is done
to announce who that cast is.
I've done a couple Fantastic Four videos
because we learned about a few members
of the cast.
Click here to learn about them and click
here for my full Loki Episode 1 Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!